excuse me what a couple I can't take it
you both look stunning and you look like
an old fairy I'm very old fairy now
you're presenting I am with my beautiful
stepdaughter Zoey yeah so it's a family
if there is it's gonna be amazing yeah
I'm very excited thank you
so we just saw Kate coming up here did
you yeah do you have a bumping sweetie I
do absolutely kid yeah okay I know you
will be seeing me soon I will be see you
soon
Ozzy today but the kids that is posted
it's great the new video came out today
right so you're just gonna have fun and
what's your family yeah it's beautiful
the best thing right and I love this
show because it's naughty you think
right it's not stuff you don't have to
sit with a stick up there good right
don't generally like to sit up sit with
sticks up my in your seat like that all
the time right
yeah I'd start throwing things yeah but
they don't let me in I wonder why so I'm
gonna give you a big kiss and thank you
for coming up to talk
get out of here get out
[Music]